hello there fortnight chapter 3 season 3
is at an end we may have been vibing all
season but there was enough story
sprinkled over the last 15 weeks to help
build out the lore of fortnite and
connect events from previous chapters
it's time for the ultimate season recap
so sit your butt down for 10 minutes and
think about using code adamaru pretty
please
to set the scene we need to jump back to
season two the resistance the uprising
led by the seven as they went to war
with the imagined order and after a
hard-fought battle they did it the io
were banished and the island was claimed
by the loopers paradigm returned to the
seven along with a new paint job for her
mech and everything was finished right
roll credits
[Music]
the first week of the season was all
about the war being over the time to
celebrate was here and the loopers began
to enjoy themselves again the island was
a party paint covered the scars of war
this was a new beginning for us all
including the zero point we freed it
from io's doomsday machine and now it
sits happily swimming in the water for
some reason it plumes out a bolt of
energy every so often that is more
important than we realized back then
strange relics of previous seasons could
now be seen in the rave cave surging
with energy oh and this season there's a
tree what could this mean
as week 2 arrived it became clear the
reality tree was spreading its roots all
over the island they could be spotted
everywhere over the course of the season
seven days later the true power of those
routes became clear this week also saw
the return of the storyline legend bill
and ted and now a third member of their
bromance the lonely trespasser from the
failed last reality invasion of chapter
two they were living in a cave but now
free they were enjoying the island just
like the rest of us
with week three came the first of many
huge map changes log jam was suddenly
taken over by the reality tree its roots
ripped the poi apart and changed it into
three distinct locations colossal
coliseum tilted town and lazy lagoon
this all started as a tiny sapling which
grew into a tree a cool memory about
this season was each reality tree poi
would change every game there was no way
to predict which one it would be it was
amazing and the moment that tree grew
another sapling sprouted elsewhere this
was the first time the scientists told
us things may not be as great as they
seem so you freed the zero point that's
great or you know maybe it has a
horrifying unintended consequence it
could go either way over the season we
worked with the scientists to understand
the reality tree one mission saw us
taking a cutting of the bush ranger and
planting him next to the reality tree
and this gave us a back bling to keep oh
in week three was also the time we first
met the scientists artificial
intelligence amy hello i am the
scientist's artificial machine
intelligence engine amy
i am the scientist's favorite so it has
been programmed and so it shall be
forever she has a few issues
week four the butterband's reality
sapling grew and once again saw the
location change every game coral castle
colossal coliseum and now neo tilted and
just like logjam they rotated through
the three pois randomly and speaking of
tilted the cleanup over there was well
underway with the repair of the clock
tower and the tidying of the rubble the
return of no sweat insurance was coming
oh and the bromance officially got a
fourth member this week after watching
the lonely io trooper four weeks bill
and ted took a chance and asked him to
join the crew
[Music]
week five one of the greatest updates to
the game arrived as a temple appeared
with something to steal inside just like
in the indiana jones movies week 5 also
saw the scientists research evolve
noting that each time we found a relic
the zero point would plume with energy
just like we saw on the first day of the
season
there it is again another zero point
energy shock wave magnitude 7.2 the zero
point has got to be bringing these
relics here because it wants us to have
them right so the scientist believes the
zero point is trying to send us relics
from other realities to prepare us for
an unseen enemy such as a sith holocron
and an ancient philosopher's artifact
another relic was the ice king shield
and it so happens the zero war comic
book brought that character back i'll
link that series if you want to know
more about that in detail
week six by this point the storyline
took a break we were introduced to the
peace syndicate a team of characters who
say they are here to help they are an
organization that keeps the peace on the
island but it doesn't feel like the
complete truth coincidentally this week
the foundation vanished that can't be
anything important right
and then came the summer update for the
next four weeks the storyline was put on
hold and instead we were given a new
waterfront fun zone and the usual summer
shenanigans the map continued to change
with sleepy sound now taken by the
reality route which was followed by
condor canyon in week 9. during this
entire period we met the face of no
sweat insurance the underwriter his
company used the summer month to take
our gold and in turn no sweat insurance
rebuilt tilted the cool thing here was
the builds were made by community
members no sweat insurance likes gold
and we like map updates so it's safe to
say this arrangement will continue
[Music]
week 11 hit and finally content began
flowing again in fortnight and what an
update dragon ball super's crossover saw
bulma join the island along with the
kame house we could all surf on clouds
and kamehameha like the show and we also
found out it isn't pronounced kamehameha
it isn't pronounced kamehameha it's
officially called call me a mama call me
a momma a monumental change was seen at
the daily bugle spider-man's poi had
been replaced with lazy lagoon how often
do you see a pirate ship inside a
hollowed-out volcano with a skeleton for
a captain yet again another relic
appeared on the island and once again we
helped the scientist get his hands on it
this time breaking a shield around a
chair that may not sound very epic but
fyi that chair has the ability to shrink
also it did in chapter two
that was magnitude 8.5 shockwave
detectable from light years away
[Music]
we are now 12 weeks into the season and
things took a turn for the worst but the
real revelation goes back six weeks the
disappearance of the foundation amy and
the paradigm senders to find the leader
of the seven yet the only thing left
behind are his work files probably for
tax purposes and his helmet the
foundation is officially missing we are
then tasked with finding the visitor and
once again he's gone he attempted to
capture something on surveillance video
but something took out that recording
without evidence he's vanished without a
trace next we were sent to search for
the imagined and we found out that she
really likes karaoke i never knew that
yet again though when we get there it's
too late all that is left behind is her
sword the paradigm is now so worried she
says this
paradigm to the seventh commence high
alert security protocols now we are
officially on high alert
luckily though there's still one more
sister we can ask the order so let's go
check up on her oh yikes she's missing
two
week 13 there's only two weeks aka a
fortnight of fortnite season 3 remaining
and this week the reality tree has
reached spawn island the roots are
stronger than ever whatever this tree is
planning it's coming very soon a
butterfly infused energy now pulses
around the roots and the reality tree
suddenly reports of chrome footsteps
were noticed as if we are sharing this
world with another reality
simultaneously but all we can do is wait
[Music]
week 14 the final major update of the
season and our task is to find the last
few members of the seven and of course
they've all gone missing luckily amy
that ai has a plan to use old com relays
to find them i don't know the science
about this but something worked and the
paradigm lets us know
i found the scientist he's in his
underground bio lab researching that
strange substance spreading across the
island the visitor is there too along
with origin
we've been asked to find and bring some
seven gear to the lab
it sounds like we're going off grid
so three of the seven are in the lab
below our feet scientist visitor and
origin yet three remain missing the
foundation and the sisters so that's six
out of seven the last one is still up
here on the island with us it's the
paradigm we finish this week with a
mission to pick up seven tech for
something going on underground but we
aren't told anymore just yet this looks
like what mr big blue and responsible
needs
i wonder what they're researching down
there
week 15 the final days of this part of
the storyline and it all sets up the
paradise season we start with a
revelation the shock waves of energy
given out by the zero point all season
were distress signals those zero-point
energy shock waves were flares a
galactic distress signal if we don't
help it'll go dormant the zero point is
begging for help calling out across
galaxies and realities we boost the
signal to help the zero point but after
the next burst of energy the scientist
is gone he frantically left a primitive
recording to let us know
if you're listening to this it means i'm
gone
i don't know where they took me and i
don't know if i'll be back
i promised we'd never leave you alone
again and i promised frame the viewer
point would be safe
everything's my fault so whatever
happens to me i deserve it
i programmed amy to take care of you and
whoever's left
i hope there are people left
i'm sorry it ended like this
and that's not the end of the bad news
moments later the paradigm is gone we
are now all alone well we do have amy
too okay
fortnite is now broadcasting ads about
the new paradise season and the chrome
which is covering everything the last
time i saw something like this it was
used to pull neo out of a synthetic
world and back to reality what will
happen in the next installment of
fortnite storyline i'm adam you're
awesome i'll see you in season four
[Music]